ما شاف خرجت عن الخدمه هو مصابون عاجزون
عن الوصول اليها حاله من الرعب والارتباك
تنتاب المرضى والكوادر الطبيه في مستشفيات
عده بالسودان وسط اشتباكات عنيفه تدور في
البلاد منذ ايام الوضع متدهور في البلاد
عشرات القتلى ومئات الجرحى ما ادى الى ضغط
كبير على المستشفيات والعاملين بالقطاع
الصحي كما ابلغت مستشفيات عن نقص في الدم
ومعدات نقله بالاضافه للسوائل الورديه
وغيرها عدا عن نقص في الكوادر المتخصصه
واطباء التخدير منظمه الصحه العالميه اكدت
ان الاشتباكات تحل دون تنقل الفرق الطبيه
فيما دعت مفوضيه حقوق الانسان بالسودان
الى حمايه المنشات الصحيه وفتح ممرات
انسانيه امنه لنقل المرضى والمدنيين
العالقين بداخلها